hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 35 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at this screen dot set offset method
that we made here and how that how that
actually control the offsets of our
tiles on our screens now well what we're
actually going to do today is render
those tiles so if I go over here to
level we've got these four corner pins
that we actually talked about a few
episodes back and we actually need to
apply them so in other words if I open
up if I open my arm
my game the owners are better for corner
pins right so in other words what we
sort of want to do is render from this
side of the screen to decider the screen
for X and from that from this side of
screen to this part of the screen for Y
so obviously that's going to be just a
full loop so let's talk about this now
so for and what will manage Y first for
in y equals out before you type 0 when
actually going to be I'm actually going
to type 0 because that's you know not
necessarily going to be 0 1 times y 0
because y 0 is the top part of the
screen so for y equals y 0 y is less
than the bottom part of the screen y1
plus plus I'm going to do the same thing
for X so for in and know this is inside
whoops that this X that I'm about to
type right here it is inside the Y the Y
loop so it's a nested for loop for in X
equal x 0 X is less than X 1 X plus plus
now I'm going to explain this code real
quick if I open up our window we know
that y 0 is up here Y 1 is down here
right X 0 is this left side and X 1 is
this whoops and X 1 is this right side
here so what I'm saying here is I'm
saying that we want to render from the
top part it's going to the bottom part
of the screen so every number in between
this very top pixel up here to this very
bottom pixel over here and also want to
render every every single arm pixel from
this this left most pixel to the
rightmost pixel all right that is what
that code is doing is cycling through
every number between the top and bottom
and the right and left with the left and
right technically okay sweet so what I
want to do now is actually you know get
the right tile to render so we can do
that very simply since by calling this
get tile method and then accessing if I
go back into our tile class you'll see
that we've got this render method in our
tile and if I go into the grass tile for
example you'll see that what that render
method actually does is it renders
equals the screens ran the tile method
and actually renders a tile out of the
screen that's what we want to do right
we want to render a talent to the screen
so we'll simply call this get tile
method by typing get tile now this is
important because we want to be able to
get the right tile to render um now it's
not actually very hard all we do is we
type X comma Y and that's it
because we need an input the exposition
inside on the Y position of the tile but
remember this is these are those
positions
all right we're dividing remember we're
dividing everything by 16 so we're
getting it into tile precision and I
talked a bit about pixel pixel precision
versus tile precision a few episodes ago
and so what we're doing here is by
dividing this X scroll value by 16 we're
actually you know being like all right
every 16 pixels equals one tile so in
other words when we actually look up
this in this array here on a specific
index you know we're saying that at
these two coordinates
what tile is there and then we find out
that if in that array the tile at least
this X comma y coordinate equals zero
then yeah we're returning in Grasse tile
otherwise we'll just return a void tile
so that is all we need to do because
remember these values are getting
getting there this Y here in this X
they're getting their values from these
corner pins and that those corner pins
are in tile precision so that's it
that's it's as simple as that you know
we've we've managed to get every pixel
on the screen in detail precision so
that our program actually knows what
tile is where and which tile ends where
and starts where so in other words it
knows that the first 16 pixels or
example is one tile so now we've called
get tile method which is brilliant what
we need to do now is actually render
them and rendering them is very simple
because you know normally when you're
calling a method you just end it like
that and that's all fine but remember
this method isn't just a void method it
actually returns a tile you can see here
that it returns a tile and so we can
actually use it to access our tile class
um like this tile don't render class as
if as if it was just you know as if as
if it was just tile dot whatever so
let's get rid of the semicolon and we'll
simply type get tile X Y which will
return us some kind of tile object and
then simply render and now when you
actually fill out these details which
are extremely easy as well they actually
all there on the screen for us already
so we're going to render them at these
positions and that's it that is actually
going to render a talented screen
now one thing I want to quickly mention
here is why we can do this now you'll
notice here that in the tile class which
is right over here we've got this random
method and it's not actually doing
anything you can see that it just sort
of exists there but there's no card
inside it and you guys might be like you
know why is it bad then it doesn't
really do anything why is that because
the thing is if we actually you know do
this so if we remove it I'm just
commenting it out which is the same as
removing it really you'll see that we
actually get an error here and you guys
might be like but hang on a minute I'm
trying to render a brass tile if I go to
my grass tile the render method exists
but the thing is we're returning a tile
we're not returning a grass tile we're
returning a grass tile yeah that method
work but we're returning a tile so in
other words even if it's returning a
grass tile object the actual method
needs to be in the tile object because
the thing is Java can't just assume that
we're going to return a grass he'll
every time
what if we're returning a void tile and
what a void tile doesn't actually have a
render method because for example I
don't know it might not render like it
does in this case but if it didn't have
a if it didn't have a random method and
we returned it it would crash because
we'll just get method not found so Java
actually says that all right if you're
if you're using classes that extend
other classes the actual superclass
which is in this case tile it has to
have a random method it has to have a
method it has to have that base method
so that you know worst comes to worst
I'll just run nothing I'll just try
almost in this code if I don't find it
in our subclasses so I hope that makes
sense
um it's not actually very easy to
understand but you know if you think
about it a lot I think you will be able
to understand it but um yeah so this
line of code over here get tile X Y the
render is going to get the the
appropriate tile at that particular
location and it's going to render it
also at this location on the screen and
that is it so I hope you enjoyed this
episode of game programming guys and I
will see you guys next time good
you